now before we get into our peers Morgan
why does so many women become Muslim
these days why want toed is that what
you're going to tell me no funding the
Muslim women why they want to beess is
that what you're going to tell me no no
why why does so many because they want
to be oppressed women in the world
become Muslim these days you tell me I
don't you better ask them why don't you
tell me what you think they they seem to
find it something that attracts them
Islam really yeah okay and also we got
this James Wales on the scene with the
talk TV I think there should be an
investigation into Ash in this show this
is James whale unleash but you have too
sure of a leash on your co-host Ash you
need a title I I don't believe a word of
what you say if I thought he had said he
thought genocide was acceptable I
probably wouldn't have on the show
anymore I probably wouldn't have on the
show anymore you know Hamas is a
minority in Gaza they need to get rid of
them they need to rise up and get rid of
them but if the people do not get up and
revolt against them does that give
Israel the right to bomb God I think it
doesn't Germany
up against the Germany didn't rise up
against the na ultimately the people are
responsible for the government can you
please have a little B I got our brother
in the studio who was just on the
program and actually had his video taken
down yeah exactly I just found out they
just took the video down copyright
stried it so I'm going to have to get on
top of it contact them and see what this
is about because you know they just had
a few other brothers on um that went on
the channel went on their show and
uploaded on their YouTube channels and
had no problem the videos are still up
there I didn't U uh edit it or do
anything shady nothing like that I just
uploaded it as is they copyright strike
me and removed the video so I got to
find out what is this all about so this
is Jake the Muslim metaphysician this is
the show I love you man all the work
that you're doing when I was ready to
talk about it I would only talk to you
expain how much respect I have for the
Fai
ofl how you been brother good
alhamdulillah good to be here bro really
excited to be here how do last time we
saw each other we were at the uh pbd huh
exactly first time we met was with pbd a
couple months ago with brother Daniel
and uh people who have been watching
your show are familiar with that Saga
and how that went down and we're going
to get into some of stuff related to pbd
recently as well inshallah but uh yeah
man that was that was a great time with
uh Unfortunately they didn't let you on
the show but um that was a great time
you know that was a great time being
with you guys there and uh inshallah uh
may meet again and you know have more
stuff going on that was interesting the
direction everything was going Patrick
uh turned out to be okay he's a good he
of course yeah Patrick Patrick and and
just to be clear was nothing with
Patrick Patrick was all for everything
he was a great host alhamdulillah he was
fair balanced and you know people can go
watch it and judge for themselves yeah
absolutely so it was nice it was seeing
like all these things were in in the in
the making the plans for having the two
sides come together Christians Muslims
and trying to have some friendly
discussions dialogues but then now it's
really taking a turn unexpected events
you see a genocide that's happening and
that's why you were on this talk
and you were calling out the genocide
yeah exactly I was calling out the
genocide and I was I was hammering them
I mean people can watch it for
themselves but I was hammering them for
10 straight minutes I was was not
letting up you know because we know
they're Mo we've seen many pro
Palestinian guests come on there even
non-muslims they do the same thing with
them you know condemn Hamas are they
terrorist organization all this kind of
stuff they want to always put the Muslim
on the back foot we need to justify
anything you know for what if Hamas ate
the wrong breakfast you know 3 weeks ago
we got to talk about it like but we
can't talk about what's actually going
down what the Israeli government has
been doing for the past 75 years what
the IDF is doing we just saw just
recently couple days ago they I mean
look at what they did to their own
hostages they shot three hostages killed
them and the guy was walking around with
a with a white flag and a big stick MH
how could he tell you any more clearly
that he's not a threat they shot him and
two other of the isra the Israeli
hostages dead so what do you think
they're doing to the Palestinian
civilians do you think they're very
cautious and they're worried about you
know harming innocent civilians when
they're killing their own
hostages no not even close so that's why
when I went on the program program I
said look you guys are in no position
you're not on any moral High Ground who
do you think you are you you're no in no
position to question me about any of of
the supposed wrongdoings you guys are
calling for genocide on your own program
and you think you can question me that's
not going to work so I hammered them for
10 straight minutes and to the point
where the host was calling for the
producer behind the scenes he said take
this guy off and he was actually
genuinely upset because the producer
refused to remove me from the show
imagine that the producer ref producer
refus the host was saying get him off
the host James whale said get this guy
out of here remove him from the show but
the the producer wouldn't remove me from
the show imagine that so I imagine after
that after that episode they must have
had James whale probably had a talk with
them and said what are you doing I told
you to remove him you didn't listen so
and and it's to the point where of
course they don't want me to expose them
as I was doing but I think they realized
that that segment was going to get good
ratings so the producer didn't want to
stop the show he didn't want to remove
me from the from the from the stream but
I had to call them out and I you know
I'm not playing games with these guys
you guys are calling for genocide and
you want to talk to me about this other
stuff no it's not going to work like
that that's the same thing uh many are
saying I mean these are qualified
experts out there Norman Fel Professor
Norman F he's also Jewish background
exactly he was also using this um
parents or Holocaust Survivors yes he
was also saying the same thing and many
others who have uh who are experts in
this area what's been happening in hza
is a textbook case of genocide and this
is a difficult topic to Broach but I
want to make the case for you because
it's something that I care a great deal
about and not just because
I'm a uh I'm Jewish uh and therefore I
care about the Holocaust or something
and not just because I am a historian of
ideas and have extensively studied
genocide so genocide studies is an
interest of mine I literally teach this
I taught comparative genocide and teach
a course on political violence in the
20th century that extensively covers
this it's something about which I've
always been involved and it's
frustrating that it's so difficult to
get people to
recognize that that's what this is
they're saying the same they're seeing
and they're seeing that the uh
International laws are being broken
exactly and these are war crimes that
are being committed exactly and and
there was new information that I
actually brought up on on the James
whale show as well uh they acted like I
don't know if you C it but they acted
like they didn't know about it so what
was this thing I brought up after I
hammered them on the genocide stuff I
don't know if you saw this Eddie there
was an article that just came out where
um they did an independent investigation
into into the bombs the Weaponry that
Israel has been using and they from
three different sources saw the material
they came to the conclusion that Israel
nearly
50% not 5% nearly
50% of the bombs that they're using and
this isn't my terminology this is
reported by CNN and major news media
Outlets the the terminology that they
used is these Israel the Israeli
government and the IDF are using what
are called dumb bombs like you know how
we have what we call smartphones right
yeah nowadays they have what are called
smart bombs where they're guided
missiles they're very precise and all of
that the dumb bombs refers to an older
technology that is based on technology
from like the 1950s right where it's not
very precise it's not very accurate
they're not guided bombs they call them
dumb bombs 50 almost 50% of the bombs
that they're dropping are dumb bombs now
check this out if it was a poor country
that didn't have a major military that
didn't have millions of funding from
Western countries like America and the
UK we could say oh well all right maybe
they don't have the the smart bombs may
maybe they don't have the technology but
America themselves are calling them out
and and President Biden which I'm going
to get to his statement in just a second
where they provided them with the smart
bombs it's not that they don't have them
to use they have the smart bombs and
they're being provided millions of
dollars for this Weaponry why are they
using this Antiquated 1950s dumb bomb
technology and this is going to be
should be investig at as a war crime why
and this is why Joe Biden if you saw
recently he mentioned that look America
we know has historically supported
Israel they've been a big backer of
Israel historically but they said look
Israel is starting to lose uh favor of
the public of public opinion and he he
what he cited was because they are
indiscriminately bombing what does that
mean well it refers back to I'm saying
about these type of bombs that they're
using they're just dropping them
haphazardly and and given the fact that
they don't have a problem killing their
own hostages waving a white flag they
don't have a problem dropping these dumb
bombs onto densely populated civilian
areas where there are women children
non-combatants and they don't care how
many of them they killed because they
are more concerned with damage rather
than accuracy they've said it themselves
and this has has to you mentioned war
crimes this has to be investigated as a
war crime under indiscriminate killing
indiscriminate bombing why are they
dropping nearly 50% of their bombs are
dumb bombs that are not guided they
don't care about Precision they keep
telling the media oh it's Hamas that
wants to kill all the civilians they
want to kill all Jews from the river of
the sea they want to kill everybody blah
BL blah but Israel cares about you know
they do all this research and they make
sure they're they're everything is
precise and all their intelligence is
precise and they just want to kill the
supposed terrorist this is all a lie
they're killing their own hostages and
they're using the dumb bombs from the
1950s seriously to the point where Joe
Biden probably not easy he doesn't want
to have to but he's at the point where
and he said it before this came out
there's a connection between them when
he made this comment about the
indiscriminate bombing two days later or
just a couple days later the report
comes out from American Intelligence
Agency of this dumb bomb situation so he
knew about it because people were
wondering what does Joe Biden know why
is he saying this he had that
information and it was released and the
story was broken by CNN just a day or
two later so this is the stuff and I
brought this up on talk TV that we've
got to expose to the people because the
propaganda is so strong from the Israeli
government they're trying to convince
everybody that they're so concerned with
Palestinian civilian life and they don't
want to kill anybody they're killing
their own hostages and they're bombing
indiscriminately and we are calling for
it to be stopped MH I want to show you a
clip here it was uh caught my attention
is by a rabbi actually and see what uh
your thoughts on it as a 19yearold
old American Jew young man trying to
find my place in the world coming to a
place where I felt like whoa you know
like Israel that's that's like my
people's country so the very first week
maybe the second or third day I was in
Jerusalem I was walking down a street
that's called Jaffa Street it goes from
the Jaffa gate to
Jaffa and there's nice old Old Stone
shops and stuff and there was a little
boy maybe six or seveny old
boy bleeding from his hand he must have
cut his hand on a broken bottle bleeding
and
crying and and and there was two
policemen there so I I went to the
boy and I said you know come with me and
I took him to the policeman and I said
to the policeman in Hebrew help help
this boy and they said to me why you
talking about he's an Arab you know just
get rid of him so that was my first
experience and I'm like whoa wait a
minute this is not
okay and I had experience after
experience after experience like that
for
me I would say 30 or 40 years
before I could like break through the
cognitive dissonance
between wanting Israel to be a good
place and the way the Jews are running
that country be a good
thing I want to believe that and the
facts right before my eyes are the the
opposite and in my brain I couldn't like
put the two together and you ask me was
there a specific incident so seriously
when the the Maui marmara which was a a
ship from Turkey sailed with six other
other ships carrying humanitarian Aid to
Gaza seriously things like School
notebooks and pencils and Wheelchairs
and
crutches and the Israelis attacked them
in international
waters and and murdered a number of
people but when I saw that I just
thought
like like I can't play this game anymore
I I like I just have to like rip off
that's a rabbi his Humanity
wasn't turned off and I was thinking
like imagine we can here at home just
visualize if you took a young boy to the
police here and they said you know
excuse my language here um I would never
use such derogatory language or call
someone using this word word but if he
said if he said the NW right please
forgive me but I'm just trying to say
just replace Arab with the nword mhm huh
yeah exactly how repulsed would we be
yeah it's just he's an Arab he's an you
know just get rid of him so that's
what's happening to the people over
there this is how they're treated
exactly yeah I mean like he said he he
even admitted it he said I went through
cognitive dissonance basically he didn't
want to accept it because he said
himself he's he's a Jew he's a Jewish
rabbi he wanted to believe that Israel
is a moral country that's doing the
right thing when he went there and saw
it for himself he realized I can't
defend this stuff imagine that a little
boy is bleeding and you show him you
know sh him away like get the heck out
of here kind of thing just completely
disgusting and it's not only him we've
heard stories yeah it's not oneoff he
said what for the next 30 years he saw
stuff like this he could probably if you
had give him more time to tell you more
stories right so you know people need to
understand this they need to stop being
duped by quite frankly the Zionist
propaganda and as we know and this is a
rabbi so it's not all Jews we want to be
clear we're not conflating Judaism with
Zionism and and you've made that very
clear on your program with the rabbis
that you've had on and everything so you
know that should be clear to the
audience but we we have to we have to
and like he said I know it's hard from
for some Jewish people and Christians as
well because a lot of them are duped
with this whole American Zionist stuff
as well which you've exposed here on the
program uh in previous episodes is
people need to take off these glasses
that they have on they need to remove
the cognitive dissonance and see what
the truth is for the s look at that with
a open mind and an open heart and have
some decency have some human decency for
a fellow human being who bleeds the same
way that everybody else bleeds the Arabs
the Muslims they they bleed the same way
that the Jews and the Christians bleed
right they're human being just like
everybody else and unless they see them
like that they're not going to get
anywhere they got to remove this layer
of cognitive dissonance and start to see
the truth for what it is it may be hard
in the beginning like for him it was
tough he didn't do it overnight but do
your own genuine research and see it for
yourself it reminds me of the Hadith uh
by Prophet Muhammad peace and blessing
be upon last final message sent to
mankind where he said there's no
difference paraphrasing between the the
non-arab and the Arab the White and the
black Y and he said this long before
civil rights in the US hundreds thousand
years before that right before anybody
was talking like this the prophet Alam
peace be upon him said this how long ago
America is just coming to that
realization in just within the past
couple hundred years right so this
should wake people up to that you know I
was just talking I was just in a mosque
earlier I was just talking to a brother
who's interested in Islam and this is
one of the things I brought up there's
no racism in Islam that's not to say
that some Muslims may be wrong and and
be racist at times every that happens
with everybody in in certain situations
but the religion doesn't teach racism
does it teach you to hate Jews no
doesn't doesn't teach you to hate Jews
doesn't teach you to hate Christians the
Quran says that the people of the book
They're not all the same this Rabbi is
not the same that as a Zionist that is
to laugh at a child that's bleeding his
street he's not the same as Ben Shapiro
exactly he's not the same as uh Ben
Shapiro he's not the same as the guy or
the guy or the guy that uh you were
calling out on the on the program
program cuz he's also yeah he's also a
Jew yeah one of the guys on there and
you were telling um wa what's his name
you were telling the uh you were telling
James Wales put him on a leash yeah I
said your show was called unleash
Unleashed but you don't have your
co-host on on on a short enough Le he's
calling for genocide on your program and
you have the audacity to question
imagine now if it was flipped exactly
imagine if I said that I and I was in
the UK I probably even be in jail yeah
there should be no genocide against
anybody and if you follow Islam youl you
can't see in any history I mean tell me
look you studied some history we've
studied and you see that genocides have
been committed can someone go ahead and
justify genocide according to the Quran
never never because and and the Hadith
are clear the Quran is clear the prophet
peace be upon Him says what he says
explicitly we cannot kill non-combatants
in war we Muslims yes it's not as if we
we're we're pacifist we don't believe in
self-defense or War when it's necessary
right of course but we believe that
there's etiquette to war there's morals
to war we cannot kill innocent women
children children elderly priests rabbis
the the religious clergy even from other
faiths it is prohibited in Islam the
prophet peace be upon Him Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said you
cannot do that that's Haram it's
prohibited and Muslims know this so any
e if a Muslim does this we don't care if
it's Hamas we don't care if it's you
know your friend Ahmed from down the
street we don't care who it is whatever
Muslim it is we don't accept that now
you're not a card caring member of Hamas
never never okay of course I'm not a
spokesman for Hamas right not at all you
see how they're trying to conflct the to
they're trying anybody who's trying to
stop the babies from being massacred
they're trying to connect them now just
like they do it on the flip side right
Eddie because what did they do on the
flip side if you're if you're anti-
Zionism you're anti-semite now you see
how they flipped it it's the same thing
if you if you're not a Zionist you're an
anti-semite really but how see if we go
into I mean how foolish is this because
if it wasn't for Islam if it wasn't for
Muslims I mean it's historically noted
this is documented Jews professors uh
historians academics come out and often
quote a David Warstein who says Islam
saved the jury exactly that if it wasn't
for Islam because you had on one end you
had the Christians persecuting the Jews
and they ran to Muslims who protected
the Jews exactly exactly can we touch
upon this when you because that's the
narrative now because they they need to
have the Zionist to have a Homeland to
protect them from the Muslims exactly
during during the Golden Age of Islam
which is sometimes called referred to
the golden period of Islam the Jews went
through their own golden age right they
they had freedom to produce their own
literature some of them were in high
ranking positions in uh political uh in
the political sphere uh they were able
to have their own court systems and Rule
you know based on their own Jewish
traditions all of that stuff I mean even
uh um one of them was a uh personal
doctor yeah exactly Ram yeah rambam who
everybody know yeah the second Moses
they call exactly so these people had
and and we're not trying to say there
was never any problem it's not like
there's never any problem it wasn't
completely perfect to be clear but it
was much better why it's because the
Muslims when they judge according to
Islam there's what Justice and peace I
just had I just had a a Muslim from Gaza
recently and I had uh Orthodox Rabbi he
was confirming it's one thing we're
talking about it but he said we flourish
Jews flourish in Muslims land Muslims
saved us so how do we get here they fled
they they they fled from the Christians
right and this is not that you know we
don't want to sit here and knock all
Christians but this is the historical
reality go and look and see even what
Jewish historians said Jews fared much
better in the Society of uh Muslims in
Islamic Society than they've ever with
with the Christians so how did we get to
a point where now many and it's not all
but many Christians and Jews now with
this whole Zionist thing are teaming up
and it's like them against the Muslims
how do we get to that point right and
that's that's something we have to think
about but you guys you guys have covered
it uh in previous programs with the
history of Zionism how it in infiltrated
through the um Scofield bible and all
this kind of stuff I I want to I want to
get into that let's uh we're going to
get into that but when you mention here
now you have this book that uh thank you
you gifted me uh Herm this uh you know
many people bring up Jihad and exactly
whatnot uh but here we see this um
Christian interpretations of Herm
passages exactly and then you had
recently um and and this is what Norman
felstein he used to support that
statement of genocide is when you're dep
depriving people of food water fuel
and then when you're sending codes like
and you're not even doing one of these
like blinking uh Netanyahu when he's out
there who was actually he's um indicted
wasn't he he was uh he was political
criminal he's about to go to jail and
now he's become a war criminal and then
he's on the TV calling the and you're
very familiar with the Bible AMC AMC so
then Norman fste Professor Norman Jewish
Professor Norman felstein he puts all
this together and he equals genocide
exactly yeah so I mean for for people
who don't know let you know let's
explain it to the audience you have this
concept in the Bible which is called
heram and this book here that I've
gifted to Eddie and I I recommend people
read it is called making sense of Old
Testament genocide this is not written
by a Muslim or you know anti-christian
people so he calls it genocide now what
does this refer to this thing uh Haram
and this is a term that we want Muslims
to start knowing and to start using
using in conversation with Jews and
Christians because it's in their Bible
we didn't put it there that's there the
concept is there and Haram if you look
it up uh basically roughly translate to
an utter destruction total Destruction
or annihilation of a people now how is
that related to amalec well amalec were
a certain people group that are in the
Old
Testament uh that existed in Old
Testament times and supposedly they're
so evil and so bad there's a lot of
propaganda around it but they are like
Enemy Number One in the Old Testament
right and there are commands now as
Muslims we don't believe this we have to
be clear on this we do not believe that
when Jews and Christians tell us that
God commanded us commanded this we don't
believe this the Jews and Christians
believe and this is actually something
that I brought up on the pbd podcast so
maybe we can link it to that as well um
amalec is said to be commanded by God to
destroy Every Woman child infant even
livestock even donkey imagine that what
did a donkey do you got to kill a donkey
too even infants in the Bible says to
kill infants total Destruction this is
what Haram is a total wiping out so when
he refers to when bib Netanyahu Benjamin
Netanyahu gets up in front of the Jewish
people
he and he uses the word amalec everybody
in the audience doesn't know what that
means but he is appealing to his base
those soldiers know what it means
exactly the on who are pushing the
buttons from the drones exactly Eddie
and he actually compared the IDF to a
figure called Joshua bin noon in the
Bible Joshua bin noon where you you see
the Book of Joshua in Joshua chapter 6
and people can go and read it literally
calls for the same thing the utter
destruction he's comparing ing the IDF
soldiers to Joshua and his soldiers well
what did they do they killed every man
woman child an infant so when he calls
the Palestinian people amalec that's a
dog whistle that's a buzzword to
energize his base to say yeah yeah let's
kill all of them this is that's a code
word for genocide get yeah people have
to know that this when they call the
Palestinian people amalekites and by the
way guess where the amalekites were what
guess where they and the Canaanites were
said to live in Palestine and where they
where they're living in Gaza right now
historically that's where the Bible says
that they describe them so they believe
genetically those people living in
Palestine are actually genetic
descendants of the amalekites the evil
people from the Old Testament so when
they say that they are calling for
genocide there's no question about it
and this is the prime minister of Israel
and we have Western countries supporting
this country when they're calling for
genocide live on air there sh this
should be shame again flip it now again
flip it now imagine if a Muslim was
doing this and someone who had some
Twisted interpretation he was quoting a
verse out of context saying kill him
wherever you find them right and now he
was saying that to people who are
actually doing it and then the host like
Piers Morgan doesn't cross-examine or he
doesn't even bring this up did did you
see one time Piers Morgan bring this up
to any of his guests nope nope the only
time I even saw it happen was and credit
to Norman finlin he brought it up on
Pierce Morgan show but that was of his
own accord and you notice when he did
Pierce Morgan didn't acknowledge it he
didn't comment on it why didn't he then
turn around and say oh that's a good
point about amalec and then put it to
the to the to the Jewish guests why is
he never pressing them on this I want to
I want to ask you I want to go back just
I want to touch upon this so this is
very important I like what you said
about we don't believe these genocidal
verses that are there in the Bible and
here's a proof here if you open up
chapter 5:32 of the Quran uh the meaning
of which is because the verse starts off
because of that I ordained for the
children of Israel that if anyone killed
a person not in retaliation for murder
and for for spreading Mischief in the
land it would be as he killed all of
mankind you know how the verse goes from
heal and saving one is night saving all
of mankind so here's the proof that
Allah God Almighty the Creator is
telling them at that time this is holds
for us even to this day that you cannot
do this you cannot kill innocent men
women children so this is a proof and
then you can use from the Bible where uh
I think it's in Jeremiah what is it
Jeremiah 88 um that the lying pen under
describes so and we know in the Quran
that Allah is also saying that woe to
those who write the book with their
hands this is versus they change exactly
and look at it this to justify yeah that
genocide even at that time was saying
exactly and we know see the the quran's
position is very clear we believe in the
original Torah that was given to Moses
we believe in the inil the the gospel
the original the original one that was
revealed to Jesus and Moses peace be
upon both of them however we don't
believe what they have now it in in
terms of it's corrupted right it's truth
Mi mixed with falsehood that's what the
the Quran says so but check this out and
that's a good thing you brought
up why did Allah subhana wa T choose to
reveal that specific verse
532 well because he knew through his own
knowledge and
wisdom that people had already changed
the scription for these Haram verses is
so he revealed this to say that's not
from me that's not for me that's deep
right because think about it this way
there's so much falsehood in there so
the Quran doesn't pick on every little
thing yes but Allah subhana wa tala in
his last Revelation to mankind which he
preserved the Quran he chose it was so
important to correct this falsehood that
they injected into the scripture he felt
it was so necessary that he had to
correct it and reveal a verse in the
Quran about it to say so that people
would know not only the Muslims so that
when the Jews and the Christians read it
they said wow that's not from God I knew
something wasn't right when I read that
you see so he's trying to get them to
think about it so the people who have
been kind of going through you know
playing the mental gymnastics and their
heart they know and they're trying to
make sense of it you you can never
really make sense of it unless you come
to Islam if you come to the Quran that's
why God Almighty Allah sent the last and
final messeng to clear all this stuff up
all this confusion exactly and that
brings me into this next clip I'm going
to play because it gets into and we'll
touch upon this clip and in there we can
kind of incorporate your story because
you went through a similar Journey
you're former Christian is right and you
really did your homework yes you
investigated investigated and led you to
Islam so let's get this is
a bishop MH Mar Mari MH and he was
recently on the pbd podcast with our
friend Patrick bent Davis so let's go
ahead and listen to this clip and we'll
get your response to it and kind of get
your story in between somewhere in there
they talk about laws I'll ask them are
you fulfilling that law of course not
you're falling very short of that law so
don't tell me you have to do this where
you are failing as a leader your prophet
failed those laws your own Prophet
failed them who Muhammad and all the
other leaders such a reporter move and
the and the very reason why Muhammad fa
because he's dead their book says that
but their book also says about my Messi
even though the ISA in the Quran is not
the Christ of the Holy Bible totally
separate people with we cannot claim
something that is not truthful I know
truth hurts I'm not offending people I'm
speaking the truth and if it offends you
I'm really sorry not I'm not sorry for
that but let me tell you one thing your
book says that Isa son of Mary went up
to heaven alive and he will come back to
judge the dead and the living if I ask a
Muslim who judges they will say God well
you're telling me this Prophet will
judge so which is which has the prophet
taken the role of God has God gone on
vacation and he's come and take his
position no but Isa is the living
Messiah even their book says there's a
lot to unpackage here yeah a lot I mean
where do you where do you want to start
uh how about um two separate individuals
so he's saying that the Jesus of the
Bible and Jesus of the Quran totally
separate yeah I mean I don't know where
he's getting this from um obviously we
just went over in the previous part of
the discussion we don't believe
everything that the Bible says about
Jesus peace be upon him right but it's
the same person right we believe he's a
prophet we believe he's the Messiah we
believe that he's uh the son of Mary of
a virgin birth etc etc right but we
believe that the Christians distorted
the message of Jesus peace be upon them
they made him into a God and now what
he's trying to do here in in in this
segment is he's saying oh and the
Muslims are basically have to concede
that Jesus is god notice what he kind of
did there he said oh even in the Muslim
book in the Muslim scriptures that Jesus
went to heaven alive and he's going to
come back which is true that part is
true we believe that isaam he escaped
death and he will come back but where
did he get this business in our
scripture about that he is going to
judge the dead and the living that's not
the role of uh Jesus peace be upon him
when he comes back to judge the dead and
the living the only thing that even if
we can give him right is that yes those
who follow Jes Jesus peace be upon him
when he comes back who are on his side
they're going to be on the right side of
history
inshallah but he's not in a position of
God judging the dead and the living in
the way that he's talking about it so
with all the respect to him I don't know
where he plucked this out of thin air
but we Muslims don't believe in what
he's saying so he's not he's not
representing our beliefs accurately and
I think that's something that we have to
note yeah I want people to um understand
this I mean and I asked many Christians
this who I had had on the program and I
asked them do you get offended when we
say Jesus peace be upon them and they
smile they right away smile if we take
it back because they'll call us Muslims
the Antichrist but you have this strange
relationship with the zionists on this
end and then you have the Christians
supporting this and and if you look into
it they're actually the Antichrist
exactly they're actually the ones if you
look into and we we don't want to repeat
the things that are said about you know
something a soft version of it is common
criminal said by Ben Shapiro what's a
common you're calling Jesus a common
criminal if you call Jesus a common
criminal in Islam you go to the Hellfire
exactly uh so we love Jesus but now
historically academically if someone
this is a f let's just unpackage this
rationally this is a false This Is A Lie
uh because this can be proven this is
this this is the same
individual uh that we're talking about
this not like he's trying to make it
seem like this is a totally different no
individual no exactly I mean it's
complete Distortion and you know there
is no disrespect to Patrick that David
I'm not blaming him for anything but
this guy is supposed to be an expert
he's supposed to be representing the
Christian religion he's on the program
speaking about Islam and with all due
respect to the platform he's he's
distorting Islam he's not representing
our belief accurately he could disagree
with our position but don't say that
Muslims we believe in our holy
scriptures that it says that Jesus is
going to come back act to judge the
living and the dead implying that oh
basically Muslims believe that Jesus is
God too because God everybody knows is
is the judge on Judgment Day so je if
Jesus is the judge according to Muslims
then what he's in the role of God he's
implying that oh basically Muslims
believe we don't believe that so they
have to you know I hope that maybe
Patrick will see this and and or some of
his viewers will see this because this
needs to be clarified I think this um uh
priest or pastor whatever he calls
himself I think he should be questioned
about where are you getting this from
you're asserting this about Islam it's
not true Let's uh touch upon this at the
same time you're because I've
interviewed so many people hundreds upon
hundreds and really what fascinated
people there's so many different things
but the basic teaching that really draws
the hearts the common sense the logic
you know it just blows everything away
that pure monotheism toed in Islam hereo
Israel the Lord thy God is one there's
no confusion about this worship one God
and Jesus repeated it in the new test
Jesus over and over and over now you can
take and we'll get into some of those
ambiguous verses uh before Abraham was I
am what else can you think about um
whoever seen me seen the father what
else and the father are one one all
these can be explained there's context
to yeah yeah but then when you look at
the clear clear verses right the Father
John 173 yes uh uh this is life eternal
that they may know the the only true God
and separate and distinct and Jesus
Christ whom you have sent what does that
sound
like the testimony of
fa and what so there's no God but Allah
yes and Jesus is sent by God is a
messenger of God that's what we believe
that's exactly what we believe and at
the time of Jesus that's what true
Muslims those who submit themselves to
the will of God they would have said
just like we say there's no God but and
there's none worthy of worship except
the one and only true creator and what
the prophet Muhammad uh peace and
blessings be upon Him is sent by that
one and only true God how long did you
because there's a lot going on right now
there's uh emotions right now for
Christian friends and neighbors this
makes sense uh they did a study over 50%
I believe it was uh Christians
Evangelical I think 30% don't believe
Jesus Is God he's a he's a good he's a
good man a good teacher so we confirm
even what the Bible say says isn't it
true that the Bible calls him a prophet
of ma Nazareth uh what other the terms
are used but there's no way messiah
messiah we we confirm word of God we
confirm son of Mary son of Mary we
confirm all this exactly but is there
anywhere in your studies and was this
also a catalyst and this something that
you had an affinity towards this basic
belief of just worshiping the god of
Jesus the one who created Jesus the one
Jesus worshiped to you can you touch
upon this yeah so uh just for people who
don't know I have a background I was
raised as a Roman Catholic my entire
family is Roman catholic christian and
um you know I always believed in God
Eddie I was never became an atheist or
anything like that alhamdulillah that
never made sense to me it's obvious that
there's a Creator right um but this idea
that Jesus peace be upon him was God and
man at the same time and he was God but
yet he came and died for our sins but
God doesn't die none of this stuff ever
made sense to me so I never really
believed in it and when I read the Quran
and its message was so clear was so
direct was so simple and I realized wow
I could believe in Jesus peace be upon
Him Islam is the only other religion
that makes it a tenant of faith that if
you don't believe in Jesus peace be upon
him as a righteous prophet and Messiah
you can't be a Muslim there's no other
religion like that now Christianity has
gone too far because they affirm that
but then they say he's God also but how
does it make sense he's God and man at
the same time well God is Immortal and
eternal he can't die but yet he came to
die for our sins and you know just
touching back because I forgot to
mention this what that guy mentioned
marari or whatever his name was on the
pbd show he said something like oh what
is this uh like is go is the Muslim God
absent why is Jesus becoming um why is
Jesus becoming uh the judge well hold on
a second what are you talking about you
believe in a God that came and died so
you believe in an absentee God why did
your God have to come and die in order
to save mankind if he's all knowing all
merciful all powerful why would God come
and die I mean this doesn't make any
sense who running the world running the
world so you're accusing us of an
absentee God I'm sorry sir but all
respect you believe in absentee God
that's an important point that I want
people to note and go and play that clip
back was he accused US based on a false
representation of our faith and yet it's
actually his faith that has that
understanding but yeah fundamentally and
this is a simple Message of Islam when I
read the Quran Eddie for the first time
I actually read the Quran with the wrong
intention mhm sincerely I read the Quran
with the wrong intention actually to
refute the Quran can you believe that
and actually like many do yeah and Allah
subhana tala Allah the most high he
still guided me wow I don't know why he
must have saw something in me right look
you're doing this for the wrong reason
but look I he he still guided me to
Islam at the end of the day with the
wrong intention when I read the Quran
and I read they they believe in one God
they worship one and only true creator
it's been the same message from the
first man Adam peace be upon him all the
way to the final Prophet with Moses and
uh Jesus peace be upon both of them in
between the all came with the same basic
message worship one and only true
creator right everyone is responsible
for thems the one of the verses and and
it really stuck out for me coming from a
Christian background no Soul shall bear
the burden of another and this is
actually in line with the Old Testament
right the son will not be put to death
for the Father the father's not put to
death always made sense to me I'm saying
Jesus and in in our religion and also
the Christians claim this too
although they actually say Paul actually
says in Galatians that Jesus is a curse
I mean could you think Eddie of a Muslim
saying that Jesus peace be upon Him is
cursed they say Jesus Is God how could
God become a curse for mankind it's just
completely Blasphemous for us and so
what I'm saying here this concept never
made sense to me in Islam we have to
believe in Jesus as a prophet as a
messenger who did many
miracles and we can't say he's cursed
this is completely forbidden in Islam
how is it the case that this innocent
man this Innocent Prophet of God died
for the sins of all the guilty this is
like me and may Allah protect me from
this this like me committing a crime and
I show up in the American courtroom and
I said judge I'm sorry but I admit it
I'm guilty I did it I shot John let's
just say you know God forbid yes and my
friend Eddie is sitting in the courtroom
right they they convict me they say okay
he's admitting to it we even caught them
on tape everything they got all the
evidence and then the sentencing comes
down and right before the judge is is
ready to put the hammer down and tell me
I got life in prison or death penalty or
whatever it is Eddie stands up and he
say you know what judge I know Jake did
it I had nothing to do with the murder
but I want to take his place can you
kill me can you take my life instead of
my friend Jake would they accept that
Eddie would the family be happy
punishing you for something that I did
to their family member of course not
this is not Justice they would say BFF
take I'm sorry Eddie would all do ECT we
got to take this guy out of here he's
he's causing a problem in the courtroom
yeah right they wouldn't accept that
this is not Justice and in Islam we
believe that mankind was created with
what we call in Islamic terminology the
fitra which is the basic innate
disposition not only to know the one and
only true God but also to have basic
moral Concepts like this a concept of
Truth and Justice that we know this is
not correct this doesn't make sense
coming from our creator with would he
want us to believe in such confusion the
Bible says that God is not the author of
confusion but yet you're telling me God
uh became a man right and God can't die
and he's Immortal but yet he died for
our sins and innocent people aren't put
to death for their the sins of their
father or the sons but Jesus became
cursed God became cursed right God
forbid God became cursed to die for the
penalty and the sins of evil
mankind what is this this doesn't make
any sense to anybody with common sense
or some decency or understanding of
human Justice it just doesn't make sense
and so when I read the Quran and it gave
an alternative narrative that made much
more sense I embraced Islam and I you
know alhamdulillah Allah subhana T
guided me at the end of the day even
though I had the wrong intention I want
people to take this seriously because
this is very important and um how do you
think now when the cognitive dissonance
kicks in and people like they've been
told so many negative things how did you
go through that moment like okay they
Tred to paint a picture like Muslims are
backwards barbaric terrorists all this
other nonsense that comes with it and
now you're seeing you're reading the
Quran you're see this is makes sense it
fits with my f like you said my natural
disposition how did you go ahead and get
through all of the negative programming
that was happening and finally take your
step forward to take uh your shahada
yeah you know Eddie I've always been a
person that um you know H has been
independent in the sense that if I think
something's right or true at the end of
the day you know I'm sorry to say with
all due respect to my family I love them
but um I have to do what I think is
right I have to accept the truth at the
end of the day and in particular uh I
was raised mainly by my mother uh cuz my
parents got divorced at a young age and
uh it was more hard on her than anything
I remember remember a story cuz and and
you know unfortunately I love my mother
but you know everybody's been s
susceptible to this um propaganda that's
been pushed especially after 911 Eddie
you know what's going on in this country
they trying to demonize Islam and it's
all about terrorism and violence and all
this kind of stuff what about U building
six we talk exactly so I mean you
everything that's going on with this
stuff and so my mom watches the news you
know unfortunately a lot of the
Americans don't know better that's why
shows like this are so important because
we have to educate not only the Muslims
but the non-muslims to let them hear
from Muslims what do we actually believe
not from Mari Mari or any of these
people Robert Spencer any of these
people telling you what we believe hear
it from us what do we actually believe
and so you know there was a time where
my friend called me Eddie and I was I
was a new Muslim I told this story
before but um just to give you an
insight into what my mother was thinking
and what many Americans are thinking
unfortunately and I picked up the phone
I I greeted my friend with the the the
greetings of Islam which is of peace I
said Asam alayum to to my friend when I
picked up the phone and that's it I
didn't go into like a I didn't know much
Arabic at the time I didn't go into a
full-blown Arabic conversation with my
friend and I was just on the phone with
him for a couple minutes I was in my
mom's uh place and I hung up the phone
and my mom turned at me and looked at me
and she said Son don't you ever speak
Arabic in my home again and I was
shocked I'm saying well and my mom
actually was a teacher she actually
spoke uh she speaks Spanish she she uh
taught Spanish in high school she taught
ESL to to to to foreigners I'm sitting
here thinking what what is wrong with
the Arabic language but they actually
demonized Islam to the point of think is
this is an Arabic religion Arabic is
actually a satanic language it it's
almost like magic or or or evil Voodoo
stuff going on just by speaking imagine
that just by saying the greetings of
Peace in Islam my mom was so put off by
it she said Son don't you ever speak
Arabic in my home again so that was
quite shocking it's very programming is
it's very difficult to deal with Eddie
know it's very difficult to deal with
now my mother how about if you if you uh
you know someone can say uh how about
can I say peace be with you see when you
define these words yeah exactly and I
told my mom said all it means is peace
Mom I'm just saying peace to my friend
peace be with you yeah and even
Christians say that in church Church you
know Eddie when I used to go to church
uh when during the prayer service and
stuff you used to shake the the the hand
of the person next to you and say peace
be with you peace be with you sir you
used to do that in the church W yes we
used to do that in the church in the
Catholic Church there's a part of the
basically Salam alayum
exactly there's there's a part of the
service and Catholics if you're watching
this you know this I'm telling the truth
tell me I'm wrong part of the Catholic
service during the the service is you
shake the uh the hand of the person next
to you and it's kind of similar right
how do we end the prayer in Islam we
turn to the right and we say what alayum
peace and we turn to the left and we
because when we're in Rose we're
standing next to two people right and
we're also um to the angels we know as
well but um and and and even in
Christianity they have the same thing
they don't do that but they they turn to
the person next to them and shake their
hand and say peace be with you imagine
that but Mom's so programmed to the
point she just heard an Arabic word she
don't understand that and even when I
broke it down obviously was in the
beginning stages now my mom has come
around a little bit alhamdulillah the
point where when I when I go to her
house or if we have a meal together
dinner and she makes something for me
she makes sure it's halal meat right
that I can I can eat right because um
you know so um what I my advice would be
if people aren't interested in Islam go
where your conviction leads you if you
believe it's the truth and you sincerely
investigate it then yes I'm not telling
you to rush in anything do your own
research take your time see what your
heart and mind are telling you and I
know it's going to be hard for people
like that in the beginning you don't
always have to come out and immediately
tell your parents right try to do it in
in a in a genuine way you know your
family better than I do but take your
time with it sinceriously seriously
consider Islam and if you believe it's
the truth take that next step and you
know take that next step
and accept Islam at least in the
beginning so you can be on the right
side of History right absolutely and
then and then deal with the other stuff
later you can you can deal with your
friends and family slowly but surely as
time goes on inshallah yes yes and and
um let's go this to this part of the um
Bishop saying that um he actually said
the bishop was saying that Muhammad
failed yeah and the very reason why
Muhammad failed because he's dead their
book says that he said Muhammad failed
yeah I I mean and then his example
example how how would you address that I
mean his example Eddie was so
Preposterous with all due respect his
example of how the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him has failed and we know
what some of these people say of his
supposed failures which we don't even
need get into he didn't even bring that
up he said his failure was that he he
peace be upon Him died he passed away he
died and and and and how is that a
failure so Eddie think about this Moses
died I was just going to say that he
took it right out of off my tongue Moses
died AB was Abraham a failure God forbid
was Moses a failure was Noah a failure
you check this out even Jesus peace be
upon Him according to them died now they
believe he came back to life but if just
dying is a failure then Jesus you know
God forbid is is a uh a failure Moses is
a failure Abraham is a failure are you
serious is this what and this is a
question to the Christians listening is
this what Christianity teaches that
Abraham peace be upon Him is a failure
the father of their religion is a
failure the father of the Jews is a
failure Moses is a failure is this what
their religion teaches and if it is they
seriously need to reconsider Islam
because we respect all the prophets we
don't say any of them are a failure
Eddie if I said that Moses was a failure
I you would you would say all right we
got to cut this off sorry Jake you're
out
we don't accept that yeah we cut the
stream right there this is we it's just
Blasphemous language I wonder if he's
thinking before he spoke I mean these
things come out the next thing he talks
about is uh I think he was trying to put
it in a sense also he mentioned that
part but then he talked about the laws
now so because Jesus died for your sins
the law is abolished and so now this is
a failure because how many Muslims live
up to the laws you cannot you know
you've heard it's all from Paul we know
it right I mean Eddie you know it from
studying the New Testament this is all
coming from Paul we see it even other um
uh quote unquote Jews who who who
accepted Jesus as the Messiah and don't
lose your place I just want people to
let's make a caveat here Paul former
Bounty Hunter can we just call that of
course yeah Bounty Hunter of Christians
yeah we can say former Christian killer
I mean that's not of really that's what
it was I mean these are facts no
disrespect anybody out there so now he
all of a sudden on his Road himself
didn't he yeah then he saw a light
supposedly yeah right that could have
who that come from like is that really
from God we don't right so let's go now
so this is the man yeah exactly so Paul
introduces this Doctrine and the Jews
and and something that the Jews and the
Muslims have in common we believe in a
law we believe in a law that we have to
follow the Jews have the Tor of course
we believe in the the last and final uh
messenger the prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him
coming with the the Quran the our
scripture and and the Sunnah his his
prophetic way um but we both
fundamentally believe in Allah law what
is the what is sandwiched in between
Christianity which all of a sudden comes
with the Advent of Paul who says well he
saw this light and and there's even
discrepancy of of the story of how it
happened in the New Testament there's
contradictions in the story so it looks
shaky from the beginning but um and we
don't know where this really came from
but but the point is he comes with this
doctrine that oh the law is a curse for
us and so then he because Jesus became a
curse from for for for us to break us
free from the law right as if the law is
evil no the law is not evil God is
telling us how to behave how to be moral
what our obligations and Duties are to
him not just oh just accept Jesus Christ
and your as your lord and savior and I'm
not trying to Tri Rize it but this a
reality for many Christians oh and then
you could go out and do whatever you
want no I mean this is just to a Jew
which as and what I want people to
realize is who were the first quote
unquote Christians of course we believe
they were Muslims but who were the first
followers of Jesus the Messiah they were
Jews so Jews would be totally opposed to
this idea of that the law is a curse the
law is bad for us we need to get rid of
it and completely throw it away this
would have been alien concept to the
Jews but Paul because he had to make a
name for himself and you know in my
personal opinion create his own religion
that's the way that he went and
unfortunately he duped a lot of people
and people are still following it today
but this is certainly not the message of
Judaism classically and it's not The
Message of Islam and it's never been the
message of Jesus PE of the prophets and
uh Islam simply meaning to submit your
will to the Creator the heavens and
earth exactly and that's how you get
peace in life and contentment so this is
the way of life that was there from the
beginning from the first man Adam is not
a new religion exact and it continued on
submit your will to the one and only one
Godly and it kept going and kept going
until today so now when he talks about
failing uh let's just touch upon this
for a second again because they try to
make it like you can't even the laws are
there but you can't even fulfill them
but you as a Muslim now how do you see
it I mean how do you see because it's a
mercy yes those at that time it became
something now because they were
rebellious and whatnot but now Prophet
Muhammad came and everything how is it
from when you wake up till you go to
sleep there are the dos and don'ts how
is this compared to your life before and
now that you have some structure and are
you able to and if you fall short are
you like cursed to the Hellfire because
you fall short how does it from a Muslim
perspective these laws well of course we
believe and we view the laws not as a
curse or anything bad we believe it as a
as a blessing as a favor from Allah
subhana wa tala because we don't believe
you know contrary to to many secularists
and these atheists that they can just
create their own moral system the Quran
says what have you seen those who have
made their own desire as a god besides
Allah this is a type of shik where
people make their own whims and desires
their own morality they don't want
anything to submit to We Believe
submission Islam is submitting your will
to be in line with what the Creator says
can we say that's the Lord's pray prayer
yeah of course or our father in Heaven
Hall be thy name thy kingdom come thy
will be done exactly exactly we want to
make sure that our will is aligned with
the Creator Creator's will this is what
Islam is it's not this just weird uh
foreign Arabic religion no this you can
be any race in in Islam in submission to
the one and only true creator and it's
always been that way and this is
something I want to get too right the
story of Adam peace be upon him cuz you
said okay Eddie you and I are not
perfect we make mistakes we sin what do
we do what what is the narrative in
Islam versus Christianity Christian
narrative is Adam and Eve see uh you
know were deceived by Satan they ate
from from the tree and now because of
that mankind is doomed basically the
their their nature is uh evil now all of
a sudden right you have this concept of
original sin now man even babies are are
born into sin and so you need Jesus to
become a man some somehow God becoming a
man so that he can you know uh restore
the the human nature to its original
thing no we don't believe in that just
as even the Old Testament says the son
is not punished for the father's sins we
don't believe in this concept of
original sin what's the difference in
Islam how does it explain the story of
Adam peace be upon on him and even some
Muslims don't recognize this it is such
a as a story for us as a
lesson how do we as you said when we
make a mistake when we fall short when
we
sin we take the example of Adam peace be
upon him the first man what did he do
what did he do and how did he get right
with his creator he made Toba he
repented to God he repented to God for
what he did wrong and God Allah subhana
wa tala the most high said I'm going to
send you Revelation I forgive you God
forgave him for what he did he made a
mistake he slipped up God forgave Adam
peace be upon him after he was sincere
he said I was deceived Lord you know I
made a mistake please forgive me he was
forgiven and God uh sent him out of
paradise and said guidance will come to
you from me and anyone that follows my
guidance they're going to be right with
God so that's what our message is when
we slip up when we know that we did
something wrong right we turn and
sincerely repent to our creator try to
amend our ways and go back to following
the guidance from our creator that is
such a beautiful message over and
against this concept of no you can never
follow the law perfectly so because of
that God has to come an innocent person
we believe Jesus peace be upon him we
don't believe he was God and we believe
he was innocent is going to die for the
sins of all the guilty do you see the
different messages in Salvation I want
the people to think which one makes more
sense what resonates with your heart
mind and soul the Islamic conception of
submission to the Creator right and
recognizing the one and only true God
and turning to him and repenting him
when you do wrong and trying to rectify
your ways or shoving it off on somebody
else that's innocent and saying no he's
going to pay for my sins I don't got to
worry about it which one makes more
sense and you can see imagine like uh
since we're replying to the guest here
of the pbd podcast podcast if you
imagine Patrick B David or any
successful person they got a strict
regimen they go by and that strict
regimen those dos and don'ts that they
apply in their life help them to be
successful it gives you structure
organization discipline exactly and this
is uh one of the things that I mean I'm
seeing it's like you just said it's a
blessing there's not too many it's not
something it's it's like um being in the
dark and you're trying to find your keys
and it's like you're lost I can't
imagine without Islam I mean imagine
Eddie imagine saying God's law is a
curse imagine saying the law of God is a
curse I mean it's so and it's like God
made a mistake now he made he made a law
for you to follow but you and it's like
he made a mistake oh I messed up now we
got oh I forgot you know I got Plan B
type of thing but really if you look at
it what are there I mean there's a few
things that are prohibitive what you got
pork alcohol and you even have the
Candace Owens I watched some of stuff
out there from many conservative
Christians who are giving up alcohol
because they're seeing
recognizing yeah exactly and what else
there's pork and we can go into the tape
bur in the brain and all the other
negative you know Health disasters and
whatnot so anything that's often repeat
God Almighty Allah loves us and whatever
he prohibited whatever is Haram is
harmful yeah letting us know it's a
favor there's wisdom Behind these laws
it's not just ha Hazard oh just don't do
this no there's wisdom behind right and
this was also prohibited at the time you
know with the uh with the church exactly
even the church and they they made a
mistake by changing their their laws and
and that's what the Quran is is sent to
rectify that but it it you know it's a
favor it's not a curse and and the the
Quran mentions this it's always a
beautiful verse that gets me to think
about things Allah the Creator
says that if you were to try if you were
to try to calculate if you were try to
enumerate all the favors that God has
bestowed upon mankind you could never
calculate it imagine that with all the
technology and the machines we have we
put all the calculators together we
create this massive calculator machine
to calculate all the favors you can't
even put all of that together and
calculate the fa favors that God has
bestowed upon man and you turn around
and your response to his favors is to
say that his law is a curse when there's
wisdom behind what he's revealed to
mankind it's just completely backwards
so Prophet Muhammad he didn't fail this
guy actually uh with all due respect he
failed with all due respect that guy
failed yes with all due respect to him
he failed yeah so a lot to I think we
have packaged most of it a few more
things uh let's jump back on Piers
Morgan what did he say about the uh
Muslim women and the hijab unbelievable
so Eddie for people who haven't seen it
and maybe we'll put the clip up and
people can do their own research but he
he was talking to a Muslim Doctor Who
was on his program and they were talking
about different things and the Muslim
doctor at one point asked him why do you
think so many women in the west are
accepting Islam are becoming Muslims
because Eddie some of the viewers don't
know I'm you know I'm a convert to Islam
I'm a revert to Islam uh but I'm a male
actually the majority of converts or
reverts to Islam from Christianity and
other religions in the west are actually
women more women are becoming Muslim in
the west than men so the doctor asked
him hey Pierce why do you think that is
now Pierce Morgan's knee-jerk reaction
was can you believe this Eddie what he
said he said why because they want to
become oppressed MH why because and then
he didn't say it just once he repeated
it a second time so it wasn't oh it just
came out wrong you know Freudian slip
they say right he repeated it again a
second time why because they want to
become oppressed what's the message
there he's conflating Islam submission
to the Creator with what oppression of
women you can't be a Muslim woman uh
woman and or want to be accept Islam and
become a Muslim woman unless you want to
be oppressed that's the message he's
trying to give to his viewers and people
called him out for that for islamophobic
rhetoric they said this is unfair why
are you why are you conflating Islam
with oppression of women you're trying
to say that women in the west only
because become Muslim because they want
to become oppressed it's nothing to do
with any of the other stuff we talked
about worshiping the one and only true
creator um believing in all of the
prophets and their message following the
laws that the Creator have given oh
that's not why they become Muslim they
become Muslim in the west because they
want to become oppressed really Pierce
Morgan that's the message you want to
give to your viewers and you want to
seem like you're objective like you're
sympathetic to the Muslims and the and
the Palestinian cause I'm sorry sir with
all due respect no we had to call you
out and and a hashtag Eddie was actually
created because of this there was you
know backlash that he received on
Twitter or what's known as X now Elon
musk's platform the hashtag boycott
Pierce Morgan because so PE so many
Muslims especially Muslim women were
appalled by what Pierce Morgan said you
are taking away from their journey to
Islam by saying they only accepted Islam
because they wanted to be oppressed
really seriously that's what you think
think so it it's just crazy and honestly
it's really disappointing to hear that
from Pierce Morgan am I shocked Eddie
all the respect honestly no because
we've seen other statements from him but
it's really unfortunate and and he has a
huge platform so it's good that we got a
chance here to speak about it and
correct this this is what I was thinking
I mean let me know what your thoughts on
I was thinking like I was trying to
figure out okay where's he coming from
like what's he up to and whatnot and I
was trying to analyze and I thought like
okay can it be that because his boss is
who he is right theer murd right yeah so
who's also the who also funds Fox news
in the US and funds talk TV the same
station that I was on with James whale
exactly so is this is it possible that
because he he sat with um the comedian
what's his name so he so he sat with
bosam our brother Muhammad
hijab um and Norman finlin the list goes
on he's brought on so many people
all these people he's brought on so many
people to go ahead and communicate the
the side our side the Palestinian side
the side of Truth here you know truth
and Justice exactly um is this his way
because if he was just to come out
boldly you know boldly and really CU
anyone who sits and listens to that I
don't think anyone who has a heart has
any part of humanity left in them can go
ahead and um not see these blatant
injustices that are that are happening I
mean what is it 700,000 we uh settlers
that are moving over imagine if you have
the migrants here that are coming over
and they they're like uh and they were
talking about build the wall they're so
concerned about the immigrants coming
from from the southern border you know
Mexico and stuff right but yet they
don't have a problem when it's with the
Palestinians imagine so imagine right
now if uh some of these conservatives
right here are just like okay they had
to deal with people from who are coming
over taking their homes m so this is
what's happening over there exactly uh
so I was thinking I was like okay is it
possible that he's just he's at least
letting the letting the truth come out
from this way and then challenging it a
little bit to kind of so he don't from
the higher ups have issues I mean what
do you think it is you know God knows
best Allah knows best as we say but um
seriously Eddie I think I think it was
more of a Freudian slip they say I don't
know if you heard this terminology where
you know deep down honestly I think he's
thinking like that and that's really
unfortunate no I'm talking about I I
understand this part with the hijab I'm
talking about from from the uh from the
other topic with Palestine from the
humanity perspective yeah I
think you know I think he may be I he
may be partial to the paltin cuse I
think he does you know recently and this
is something I I I pointed out uh well
actually I didn't get a chance to point
pointed out so I mention it here yeah if
you go back and watch closely uh Eddie
when he had Norman finlin on um and I
I'm recommend that people watch that
because Norman finline gave a great
presentation very good um in his
discussion with Alan dershowitz who's a
Zionist lawyer from the
US um and we all due respect completely
destroyed the guy but anyway people
could watch it and judge for himself
when he was on the program if you watch
closely Eddie and this is important
towards the end of the program Pierce
Morgan actually called Gaza occupied he
said the occupation of Gaza over the
past 75 years has been terrible and I
disagree with you Alan dtz about the
blockade being a good thing the blockade
is not a good thing and the occupation
of Gaza over the past 75 years has been
terrible so you know God knows best what
his intentions are it's kind of
difficult to say cuz on the one hand he
makes these kind of islamophobic
comments on the other hand now all of a
sudden and then notice this happened
this thing when he mentioned that with
um Norman finlin was after he said that
so now was he only calling it occupation
because he re received backlash does he
genuine feel genuinely feel that way
Pierce Morgan if you're watching this
next time you go on the program brother
blink twice you know if if you if you're
trying to give us a message blink twice
you know call for help but I don't know
and we want the I mean I mean you could
probably agree we want the best for him
of course yeah we don't want him to be a
hater of Islam yeah I mean we want him
to be guided to Islam exactly and then
Andrew Tate invited him to Islam did you
see that exactly towards the end he said
he said look I we want you to come to
Islam Peter yeah and Andrew Tate he he
called himam doing the da yeah he was
doing the da and then uh I think that's
when it break it abruptly came to an
end he's like okay we got to cut we got
to cut yeah all right last thing I want
to touch upon I think this is extremely
important I think this is extremely
important for people who don't know
about this topic I had recently a senior
pastor on he was with uh I think CNN CBN
and all these Pastor Rick and he did a
great job of explaining and you know
much of this and many people don't and I
think it's important because you have a
lot of Christians who preach love your
neighbor and those verses from from that
we agree with you know Jesus Prince of
Peace and but then you have these uh
innocent babies being massacred right in
front of us and they're silent and
probably because they feel like that
this is a part of their faith it's a
credle thing now because these push
prophecies whoever blesses these is we
blessed whoever cursed D be cursed and
it goes back to the pastor and I asked
them how can Christians support this not
all but some in the US and he said this
is because of the con man scoffield
Cyrus then he took it he took it back to
John Elsa Darby let's touch upon this
this is extremely important because when
we unpackage this we see like this was
put together
by conmen and this is Zionist propaganda
in the footnotes interpreting these
misinterpretations of this so it's
actually not a part of Christianity for
the first 1800 years nothing to do with
Christianity you can and many Christians
also I think you had I've shared some
things with you on sh yeah and this is
very important so Christians The Mask
can come off you know the UN programming
they could be like I don't have to
support this it's not a part of my
Christianity no it's not M and
especially the Catholics said
historically the Catholic church and
unfortunately Islam is in it's mentioned
in the Quran we are a middle Nation
we're in the middle we're in the we're a
middle Nation we're a balanced Nation
previously
unfortunately um prior to this American
Zion stuff that they have now the
Christian church was actually the
opposite they were sort of anti-Semitic
almost in a way they were very against
the Jews because they believed that the
Jews were responsible for killing their
God they used to call the Jews God
killers really this is what they believe
so how do we this is not a this they
would call them Christ Killers exactly
God you guys are responsible for God and
it goes back to this passage in the Book
of Matthew where um basically he says
the the the blood uh the blood is going
to be on our our children's hands right
and so it's basically this pass down
thing and so you know it it's weird how
do we get to this way why how did the
Christian Nation go from almost
anti-Semitism anti- Zion is M to now
complete and not all of them because
you've had pastors on your program I've
showed you Christians who are against
this stuff who know this is not historic
Christian position um calling this out
now but why are so many Christians been
duped by this where did this come from
well John Nelson Darby couple hundred
years ago we know the guy was a con man
just given a short story um basically
came up with this strange Doctrine he
had this idea of you know uh when the
Messiah comes comes back it's going to
be in Jerusalem and the Jews have to be
there and this whole long story and
everything and then from from John
Nelson Derby eventually we had this guy
called scoffield
Scofield yeah he's a Comm man who um was
responsible for he created his own Bible
not that he made up his own verses but
what he did was cleverly just like
Muslims who are watching may be familiar
with t Seer what's called ex Jesus of
verses of the uh Quran he put in his own
exegesis all throughout the pages of his
Bible in which he was interpreting in a
way that was going towards this Zionist
moving oh the Jews need to be in
Jerusalem in order for the Messiah to
come back and all this Jazz about the
some people have seen about the red
heers these cows what is all this stuff
about all of this he put in in his
Scofield bible and people don't take my
word for it don't take Eddie word for it
do your own research there are
Christians pastors that are admitting
this Eddie that this was never the
Christian position and they're calling
Cyrus scoffield out for being a fraud
for being a crook that this is what he
did he he created his own Bible injected
it in there and then from there he had
uh basically millions of co uh copies
dispersed first in in widely in the
churches and
then and of course cuz part of the
Zionist project influence people because
we know Eddie people don't come up with
their ideas out of nowhere right it's a
lot of propaganda through this you know
fake type of education or nowadays media
propaganda but back then they put it in
books they put it in all the churches
all these Scofield Bibles released it
for free in all these churches and then
after that they moved on to Academia to
having it taught in the universities in
all the prestigious universities and
colleges especially in the US to
influence young people to believing this
thing all the way up until um you know
modern times where they made movies
about this no man Left Behind or
whatever it's called and all this kind
of stuff you know it's just they had the
late great planet Earth Lindsay that
sold like 40 million copies yeah exactly
all this kind of out big time exactly to
push it out through through through
media through movies and and now a lot
of people have been duped but now with
Advent of social media and the internet
people have more information accessible
to them it's sort of double-edged Sword
because there's a lot of misinformation
spread but on the other hand a lot of
Christians are waking up to the fact
when pastors are speaking up about this
look you can be a Christian and not
being a Zion be a Zionist you don't have
to blindly support the state of Israel
and whatever they do and what Netanyahu
and their government say and whatever
the IDF this isn't your religion this
isn't your religion that you must be a a
Christian Zionist and they're calling
this stuff out and we need to highlight
this and expose this to a larger
audience here here's one example uh
Jesus will come back twice they say yeah
according exactly they have this concept
of the Rapture Ed that it's not in and
this is nowhere in about this is not in
the Bible Jesus will remove Christians
take them to heaven and then there'll be
seven years of tribulation then the
Antichrist will attack Jews and Israel
and then Jesus will come back and save
the Jews as Z this it's so it's a pretty
much it's a Zionist Doctrine which took
over the Christian churches in America
so this has nothing according to
Christian Scholars people who are
experts in this area who are coming out
this has nothing to do with the biblical
teachings biblical prophecies and
they're saying it exactly as we said it
Eddie these are not our own words
they're the Christians are telling us
Dave told us experts who've done the
research they said look The Narrative
that I just gave Eddie and Jake didn't
come up with this right Eddie we didn't
we who's that he's one of the leading um
leading uh Christian James James Dr
James White James White he even called
out a fellow Christian Dr Michael Brown
who's this Jews for Jesus kind of guy he
called him out and he said look with all
due respect Michael I see you as a
friend but you can't show me anything
where you're saying actually in the
Bible and I challenge you it's nowhere
in the Bible this is this is Darby ISM
this is Scofield ISM this is not genuine
Christianity this is not traditional
Christianity that was taught throughout
the first 2,000 years of the church or
you know a little less than 2,000 years
of the church and so it's really
unfortunately a lot of people have been
duped Eddie but you know glad that we
have this platform and other platforms
where we're bringing on uh pastors to
speak about this and they're speaking
out on their own to say to let you know
like Christians wake up you don't need
to buy into this Israeli propaganda and
what they're pushing in some of these
churches this is not your what we would
call AA this is not a fundamental belief
in their faith to believe in this kind
of stuff there's no Rapture and Jesus
coming back twice and all this kind of
stuff they created movies about this
Eddie they made money off of it and now
they're pushing for power and
unfortunately genocide against the
Palestinian people and we need the
Christians to see this and wake up to
say you know we're not asking of course
we want them to be guided to Islam but
at the very least wake up and stop
buying into this foolishness mhm thank
you we covered a lot alhamdulillah it's
good to see you again appreciate it I'm
glad you guys had me on and uh it's a
blessing and uh look forward to doing it
again sometime last closing words and
comments for the person that's tuning in
for the first time he likes this message
of pure monotheism we talked about he
didn't know that Muslims love Jesus we
say peace be upon him and many things
doubts were cleared up they're seeing
also now the the uh blatant um hypocrisy
that's happening you know with many of
the politicians and they're not stepping
up to
stop the slan is never again but did
that exclude the Palestinians so just in
a nutshell what would you give for the
for the person who's out there youd like
what we had to say what advice would you
give them you were also former Christian
uh what would you say closing words
comments yeah my my recommendation would
be if you haven't already pick up a
Quran I think Eddie can plug it at the
end there's a place where we can ship
you a free Quran from here and there
plenty of organizations doing this you
can read the Quran uh online as well for
free I recommend if people are sincere
um sincerely consider Islam concer uh
consider
sincerely um reading the Quran for
yourself speaking to actual genuine
Muslims in your community go to a local
mosque speak to the local Muslim
Community in your area be around Muslim
Muslims see how they behave see how they
treat other people see how they interact
with you is every but all Muslims out to
get you and do we want to just you know
cause violence in in the land and and do
all this bad stuff see it for yourself
don't get it from Fox News and all these
different programs go to your local
Muslim Community speak to them see how
they treat you get a copy of the Quran
read it with an open mind and an open
heart and ask the creator of the heavens
and Earth to guide you to the truth to
guide you to the truth and see where it
leads you right do your own research I'm
not saying accept Islam now no no do
your own research sincerely consider
Islam read the Quran for yourself ask
for guidance from the one and only true
creator Allah subhana wa tala the most
high who why by the way which we didn't
mention Allah it just means the god in
in from Arabic we don't believe that
it's it's not yeah it's not a different
God it's not an Arabic God or anything
like that right so it's perfectly fine
to say God in English and and and really
just sincerely think about it consider
Islam read the Quran for yourself open
your mind and your heart and ask and
pray for guidance and we we hope that uh
Allah will the creator of the heavens
and earth will guide you to the one and
only true Faith Islam submission to him
Jake the Muslim metaphysician thank you
for sharing that with us and very simple
homework ask the creator of the heavens
and earth alone for guidance and if
you'd like to see more of what we've
been talking about we mentioned the
Quran you can get it for free at the
Deens show.com until next time peace be
with you assalam alaykum I'm sure all of
you know Eddie from the dean show and
I'm sure that you've all heard about the
dean center now you don't want to miss
on this opportunity the brother has been
around for a long time when I became
Muslim that was a show that I used to
watch it was one of the shows that I
actually was interviewed on and since
then I've kept in touch with Eddie and
we've cooperated and participated in
many things together alhamdulillah by
the blessings of Allah now you guys have
to do your part this is for the umah
there's so many people in this world who
need The Message of Islam but the
question is now what you're going to do
what are you going to do with your money
with what you have what are you going to
do to help the umah to help someone
who's been around for 20 years doing
dawa you've enjoyed the shows you've
enjoyed the interviews you've enjoyed
now it's your turn support the dean
Center